Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Slowly the soldiers moved with lagging steps, dreading that they had crossed the spreading globe only to pass into forbidden realms in defiance of nature and heaven. But Hannibal was having none of it. Not for him any terror of the Alps, not for him any horror of the snows. "'Shame on you,' he cried, "'to weary of fame and despair of the favor of the gods.
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想获取每周独家播客、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。士兵们迈着沉重的步伐缓缓前行，心中充满了恐惧：他们跨越了广袤的世界，如今却要违背自然与上天的意志，涉足这片禁区。汉尼拔可不吃这一套。阿尔卑斯山的恐怖吓不倒他，皑皑白雪的阴森也动摇不了他。
Shall we retreat after all we have won before snow-capped mountains, cowed and beaten by cliffs?' No, comrades, no. Onwards we go. Believe me, that soon we shall be scaling the walls of Rome, that mightiest power, and the steep hill of Jupiter, at which all his men cheered and found their courage restored." restored. So that was Silius Italicus. The Punica is the name of that poem. He wrote it almost 300 years after Hannibal's invasion of Italy in the reign of the Emperor Domitian. Tom, it's the longest surviving Roman poem. It was beautifully read, I thought. I was magnificent. Thank you. That's kind.
他大声喊道：“难道在白雪皑皑的山峰面前，在悬崖峭壁的威慑和击溃下，在我们赢得了这一切之后，我们还要选择撤退吗？”不，同志们，绝不。我们继续前进。相信我，不久之后，我们将攻克罗马那最强大力量的城墙，登上朱庇特的陡峭山丘。众将士听罢，欢呼雀跃，重拾了勇气。恢复了勇气。西利乌斯·伊塔利库斯就是这样写的。那首诗的名字就叫《布匿战事》。他在罗马皇帝图密善统治时期写下这首诗，大约是在汉尼拔入侵意大利近300年之后。
Yeah, really good. It's a shame I had to prompt it, but I'll take it all the same. Now it's proof, isn't it? Of just how deeply the experience of fighting Hannibal and the personality of Hannibal were seared into the Roman imagination. And actually you get the sense there of their massive respect for Hannibal. You know, he's not a, we talked last time about whether or not they see him as a super villain.
汤姆，这是现存最长的罗马史诗。我觉得它朗诵得非常美。太棒了。谢谢。你过奖了。
Maybe they do, but they clearly see him as a serious person, as somebody worthy of admiration as well as fear. Absolutely. And they always acknowledge his supreme genius as a general and there's a certain self-serving quality to that because obviously if he's the world's greatest general and they've beaten him, that redans very well to their credit. But I think that what you see there and also what you see in that passage from Juvenal that you read again very beautifully in the previous episode, so you've got an epic poet in the form of Silas Italicus, you've got a satirist in the form of Juvenal,
对，真的很不错。真可惜我刚才还得提示你，不过我还是全盘接受了。现在这成了证明，不是吗？证明了与汉尼拔作战的经历以及汉尼拔的个性，在罗马人的想象中留下了多么深刻的烙印。事实上，你从这里能感受到他们对汉尼拔的极度敬畏。你知道的，他并不是一个——我们上次讨论过他们是否把他视为超级恶棍。
and what they're both fixing on in particular as emblematic of everything that makes Hannibal extraordinary, is this feat in crossing the Alps. It makes Hannibal seem like Hercules, which is part of Hannibal's plan. That was what he was going for. Makes him seem superhuman. To climb the Alps, to fend off all the predatory barbarians that lurk in its snowy wastes To gaze down from a mountain pass at the fields of Italy Impossible and yet Hannibal has done it. Yeah, and we left him at the end of our previous episode
也许他们确实这么看，但他们显然把他视为一个重要人物，一个既让人恐惧又值得钦佩的人。绝对是这样。他们总是承认他作为将领的至高无上的天才，这其中也带有某种利己的成分——很显然，如果他是世界上最伟大的将军而他们战胜了他，这会极大地增添他们的光彩。但我觉得，你在那里看到的，以及你在上一集中再次深情朗诵的那段尤维纳利斯的选段中所看到的——你既有一位史诗诗人（西利乌斯·伊塔利库斯），又有一位讽刺诗人（尤维纳利斯），
He's climbed all the way up the Alps he's reached the very summit of the past that he's been aiming for and he's telling his men, it's brilliant, here we are, there's nothing to worry about, Italy lies below us, let's get down there and take the fight to the Romans. Exciting, so we're in 218 BC aren't we, second Punic War, Hannibal is some, his great strategy is that he's not going to wait for the Romans to attack him. He's going to go for it. He's going to get into Italy. He's going to separate them from the allies. He's going to, and his aim is Rome itself, an amazing ambition for Carthaginian
他们两人特别聚焦、用以象征汉尼拔超凡脱俗之处的，正是翻越阿尔卑斯山这一壮举。这让汉尼拔看起来就像海格力斯，这也是汉尼拔计划的一部分。这正是他所追求的效果。这让他看起来超乎常人。攀登阿尔卑斯山，抵御潜伏在雪原荒地中的所有凶残野蛮人，从山隘俯瞰意大利的平原，这本不可能，然而汉尼拔却做到了。是的，我们在上一集的结尾把丢下了他——
general. And so his men who were very kind of demoralized and all got frostbite, they get hungry, they've been attacked by ghouls all the time, all a bit miserable. When they get to this pass, Hannibal, according to Livy, gives his men a very positive briefing and he says, it will be very easy going from this point on. There are no more hills to climb, a battle or two, and we will have Rome in the palm of our hands. But of course, Dominic, anyone who has climbed a very steep hill will know that actually going down can sometimes be as tough on the legs as going up. This is a great act of imagination by you, which all great historians have, because you
他一路爬上阿尔卑斯山，到达了他一直渴望抵达的山隘之巅，并且他告诉手下：太棒了，我们到了，没什么好担心的，意大利就在我们脚下，让我们冲下去，把战火带给罗马人吧。令人兴奋，所以我们正处于公元前218年，对吧，第二次布匿战事，汉尼拔的伟大战略在于他不打算坐等罗马人来进攻他。他要主动出击。他要进入意大利。他要将罗马人与他们的盟友隔离开来。他要——他的目标就是罗马本身，这对于一个迦太基
of course have never been to the Alps. And yet you can imagine that it's very difficult to go down them. Yes, and particularly with an elephant. And that's the power of imagination, Dominic. Well it's not just imagination, it's about your sifting of the sources, isn't it? For sure. Doesn't Polybius, the Greek historian, tell us that it was very difficult and lots of people fell off the mountain as they went down the hill? Shall I read the passage in which he says exactly that?
将军来说是何等惊人的雄心。因此，他的士兵们士气低落，个个冻伤，挨饿受冻，一路上不断遭到山民的袭击，过得有点凄惨。当他们到达这个山口时，据李维记载，汉尼拔对部下发表了一番充满鼓舞的讲话，他说，从这一点开始，一切都将轻而易举。再也没有需要攀登的山丘了，只要打上一两场仗，罗马就会被我们稳操胜券。但当然了，多米尼克，任何爬过极陡山坡的人都知道，下山其实有时和上山一样对腿力是个巨大的考验。这是你展现出的非凡想象力，所有伟大的历史学家都具备这种能力，因为你
Yeah. So Polybius says, so this is about the descent and how treacherous it proves. The track which led down the mountainside was both narrow and steep, since neither the men nor the animals could be sure of their footing on account of the snow. Any who stepped wide of the path or stumbled over balanced and fell down the precipices Yeah And this is obviously very bad news for I guess for for horses or elephants if they if they slip Because they're really gonna make it a din However, you know, it's got to be done and as they go down the snows start to kind of melt a bit and they start seeing
当然从来没有去过阿尔卑斯山。然而你能想象下山是非常困难的。是的，特别是还要带着大象。这就是想象力的力量，多米尼克。好吧，这不仅仅是想象力，这是关于你对史料的仔细甄选，对吧？确实如此。希腊历史学家波利比乌斯不是告诉我们，过程非常艰难，许多人在下山时从山上摔了下来吗？要不我把他说得严丝合缝的那段读出来？
um, pines and other foliage clinging to the rocks and it all looks to be going great. And then suddenly there's a massive traffic jam and Hannibal is not at the front of the column, but suddenly, you know, elephants are piling up and horses and mules and Spaniards and Balearic slingers and everything. And so he's forcing his way through this ever narrowing path to see what the problem is. And he discovers ahead of him, the debris of two separate landslides. And the first landside has carried away an entire stretch of the mountain. So the face of the mountain, and the second of the mountain. And the second one
好的。波利比乌斯是这样说的——这是关于下山以及过程多么险峻的描述：通往山下的山路既窄又陡，由于积雪，人和动物都无法站稳脚跟。任何偏离小路或绊倒的人都会失去平衡，跌落悬崖。是的。这对于马匹或大象来说显然是个极其糟糕的消息，如果它们滑倒的话，因为它们会弄出极大的动静。然而，不管怎样，事情必须完成。随着他们往下走，积雪开始有些融化，他们开始看到
has kind of added to the general impassibility of this path that they've got to take down. And it's clear to Hannibal immediately that there's no way that the horses, let alone the elephants, can get past it. And most of his men won't be able to either. The situation is very, very tricky because there are rock falls, there's still snow. You can't go forward. There's no detours that are possible. So it's kind of very, what is it going on a bear hunt? They can't go over it. They can't go under it.
松树和其他枝叶紧紧依附在岩石上，一切看起来都在往好的方向发展。然后突然之间，交通大堵塞了。汉尼拔不在队伍的最前端，但突然间，大象、马匹、骡子、西班牙人和巴利阿里群岛的投石手等等挤成了一团。于是他在这条日益狭窄的小路上艰难前行，想看看出了什么问题。他发现在他前方有两处独立的泥石流残骸。第一次泥石流冲毁了整段山体——山崖的面貌，而第二次
They've somehow got to find a way to go through it. Yeah. So what Hannibal does, he orders his mentor retreat to a ridge that's looking over this kind of blockage of debris to clear it of snow, to make camp there. And then he thinks, well, what am I going to do? And it's been mentioned by Juvenal in that passage that you read the previous day where he talks about how Hannibal dissolves rock with vinegar. And if there are scientists listening, perhaps they could let us know if this is actually feasible or not. But I'll report what Livy says. Livy says that the job that faces Hannibal is to essentially to clear away the rubble and somehow construct
则进一步加剧了他们必须通过的这条小路的不可通行状况。汉尼拔立刻明白，马匹绝无可能通过，大象更不用说，他的大部分部下也将无法通过。形势非常非常棘手，因为有落石，还有积雪。你无法前进。没有任何可以绕行的路线。这有点像——捉熊记是怎么唱的来着？他们无法翻过它。他们无法从它下面过去。
a new path out of the precipice, out of the kind of the sheer wall of rock, because there's no other way down. So they have to cut through the rock and the way that Hannibal does this is he solves it by the ingenious application of heat and moisture. Large trees were felled and lopped and a huge pile of timber erected. This with the opportune help of a strong wind was set on fire. And when the rock was sufficiently heated, the men's rations of sour wine were flung upon it to render it friable. So that's the vinegar. The wine essentially has become vinegar.
他们必须想方设法穿过去。好的，所以汉尼拔的做法是：他命令部下撤退到俯瞰这处残骸堵塞点的一个山脊上，清理积雪，在那里建立营地。然后他想，嗯，我要怎么做呢？尤维纳利斯在你前一天朗诵的那段里提到过，他谈到汉尼拔如何用醋溶解岩石。如果有科学家在听节目，也许他们可以告诉我们这到底切实可行与否。但我来转述一下李维的说法。李维说，摆在汉尼拔面前的任务基本上是清理碎石，并从悬崖峭壁中、从那陡峭的岩壁上硬生生开辟出
They then got to work with picks on the heated rock and opened a sort of zigzag track to minimize the steepness of the descent. And you can see why this is a feat that particularly resonates with Hannibal's enemies. And I mean, to his admirers, it must have seemed an astonishing feat to carve a road out of the sheer rock. I mean, it really is the kind of the stuff of a Greek hero. Yeah. I mean, clearly there is a measure of truth to this. There clearly was a landslide because otherwise it's hard to see why these reports would have come from. So they do get down. They must be incredibly hungry at this point because they presumably
一条新路，因为没有其他下山的路了。所以他们必须凿穿岩石，而汉尼拔采用的方法是通过巧妙地运用热力和水分来解决问题。砍倒并修剪大树，堆起巨大的木柴堆。在强风的适时帮助下，这堆木柴被点燃了。当岩石被烧得足够热时，士兵们的酸酒口粮便泼了上去，使其变得酥脆。这就是醋。这酒实际上变成了醋。
have been delayed on the mountain and they're running short of rations and stuff and it's raining and snowing and all this kind of thing. But finally they do get down, you know, and all is sweetness and light, right? They arrive in these valleys and we're told that it's sunny and the streams and they can, you know, all have a rest and sort of flop down by the side of a bank of a river or whatever. And what's the plan then? That presumably they're just going to go for it. They're going to strike south towards the sort of the plane of the power towards what's now Turing and stuff. I mean, I think even Hannibal recognizes that there's an absolute need for everybody to recharge their batteries. So it's not just the men who are shattered, obviously the horses,
接着他们用镐在被加热的岩石上开工，开凿出一条类似之字形的小路，以最大限度地减缓下山的陡峭度。你可以看出为什么这是一个让汉尼拔的敌人产生强烈共鸣的壮举。我的意思是，对于他的崇拜者来说，在峭壁中开凿出一条路，这一定是一个令人惊叹的壮举。我的意思是，这真的可以说是希腊英雄才会做的事。是的。我的意思是，这里面显然有几分真实性。显然发生过泥石流，否则很难解释为什么会有这些报道流传下来。所以他们确实下山了。此时他们一定饿极了，因为他们大概
the mules, the elephants, you know, there hasn't been much food up on the mountains. So they are put out to pasture, the troops are given three days R&R, and as you say, they come out kind of pretty near where Turin stands now. And it had taken them in all just over a fortnight, so 15 days to cross the Alps. And it had been five months since the army's departure from New Carthage in Spain. And the whole expedition had come at terrible cost. So by Polybius's reckoning, 50,000 infantry had left the Pyrenees. And of these, only about 20,000 remain.
在山上耽搁了，口粮正在告罄，而且又下雨又下雪诸如此类的。但最终他们确实下山了，一切又都皆大欢喜、一片祥和了，对吧？他们来到了这些山谷，据说那里阳光明媚，有溪流，他们可以（你知道的）好好休息一下，倒在河岸边或随便什么地方休息。那接下来的计划是什么？大概他们要全力以赴了吧。他们要向南突围，朝着波河平原，朝着现在的都灵之类的地方前进。我的意思是，我认为连汉尼拔也认识到，绝对有必要让每个人都补充一下体力。所以不仅是士兵们精疲力竭，很显然还有马匹、
So over half have perished on the route. And of the 9,000 horses, only 6,000 remain. Wow. So what Hannibal had done was summed up later by another great general who led his troops over the Alps and was portrayed famously as doing such by David, the great painter of the French Revolution, that was Napoleon. And Napoleon, of course, very, very aware of Hannibal's example. And he said of this crossing of the Alps that Hannibal had sacrificed half his army merely to acquire his chosen field of
骡子和大象，山上的食物并不多。所以它们被放出去吃草，部队得到了三天的休整（R&R），正如你所说，他们出来的地方相当接近现在都灵所在的地点。他们总共花了刚过两周多一点的时间，也就是15天穿过了阿尔卑斯山。而从军队离开西班牙的新迦太基算起，已经过去五个月了。整个远征付出了极其惨重的代价。按照波利比乌斯的估算，有5万名步兵离开了比利牛斯山脉。其中，只剩下大约2万人。
battle, the opportunity to fight where he wished to. And I guess kind of hanging in that comment, perhaps people might think, well, was it worth all the effort that Hannibal went to? Was it worth the loss of over half his army? And Dominic, you said in the previous episode, you asked, would it have been possible for Hannibal to fight Scipio on the banks of the road? Yeah. He could have done that, but that's not actually what Napoleon is saying. Napoleon's comments on Hannibal sacrificing half his army to get where he
因此，过半的人在途中丧生。在9000匹战马中，只剩下6000匹。哇。所以汉尼拔所做的事，后来被另一位伟大的将军所总结，那位将军也曾率领部队翻越阿尔卑斯山，并且在法国大革命的伟大画家大卫笔下被描绘得极为著名，他就是拿破仑。拿破仑当然对汉尼拔的榜样非常非常了解。他谈到这次翻越阿尔卑斯山时说，汉尼拔牺牲了半数军队，仅仅为了获得他心仪的战场，
wanted to, to get his chosen field of battle is not meant as a criticism. I mean, this is the kind of thing Napoleon did all the time. He'd sacrifice hundreds of thousands of men to get his army into the position where he wanted to fight because what Napoleon is recognizing and is clearly the case is that by bypassing Scipio, by refusing to meet the Romans on the Rhine, by getting into Italy, Hannibal has kept the initiative. But Tom, can I jump in and make an observation? Yeah, of course. We compared Hannibal, or you compared I jump in and make an observation? Yeah, of course.
获得在他希望的地方作战的机会。我想，在这个评论的背后，也许人们会想：汉尼拔付出的所有努力真的值得吗？牺牲一半军队真的值得吗？多米尼克，你在上一集中说过，你问过，汉尼拔有可能在罗讷河畔与西庇阿交战吗？是的。他本可以做到这一点，但这并不是拿破仑实际所表达的意思。拿破仑关于汉尼拔牺牲半数军队来换取他想要的地方、获取他心仪的战场的评论，并不是一种批评。我的意思是，这正是拿破仑一直以来在做的事情。为了让他的军队到达他想要作战的位置，他会牺牲几十万人的生命，因为拿破仑所认识到并且显然是事实的是：通过绕过西庇阿，通过拒绝在莱茵河与罗马人会战，通过进入意大利，汉尼拔保持了战略主动权。但汤姆，我能打断一下并发表一个观察吗？对，当然。我们把汉尼拔，或者你把——我能打断一下并发表一个观察吗？对，当然。
We compared Hannibal, or you compared him in a previous episode to Charles XII of Sweden. A commander who has a lot in common with Hannibal and with Napoleon. You know, they're swashbuckling, they're charismatic, they captivate all Europe, they take the initiative, they sacrifice a lot of men for an advantage. And the other thing that all three have in common is they all end up losing. And they do that partly because they throw away men thinking, well, you know, vim and vigour matter more than manpower. But the Romans could have told all three of those people that manpower matters more than
我们把汉尼拔，或者你在前一集里把他比作瑞典的查理十二世。一位与汉尼拔和拿破仑有很多共同之处的统帅。你知道的，他们行事鲁莽、极具个人魅力、迷倒了整个欧洲、掌握主动权、为了利益牺牲了大量士兵。这三者共同的另一个特点是，他们最终都失败了。他们之所以会这样，部分原因在于他们抛弃士兵，认为“嗯，你知道的，冲劲和活力比兵力更重要”。但罗马人本可以告诉这三个人：兵力比任何东西都重要。
anything. And that is exactly the challenge that Hannibal recognizes. Hannibal absolutely appreciates that it is the manpower that the Romans have that is the huge problem and that's why he's come to Italy because his only prospect of defeating Rome is to secure the backing of people in the peninsula of Italy. Okay, that's interesting. So he's sacrificing men now to gain men later. That's his thinking. Absolutely, because his arrival in Italy is designed to terrify and
而这正是汉尼拔所认识到的挑战。汉尼拔完全清楚，罗马人拥有的兵力才是那个巨大的难题，这就是他来到意大利的原因，因为他击败罗马的唯一希望就是争取到意大利半岛上人民的支持。好吧，这很有意思。所以他现在牺牲士兵是为了以后赢得士兵。这就是他的想法。绝对是的，因为他抵达意大利就是为了吓唬和
intimidate the Romans, which it does. And the moment he arrives in Italy, this desperate summons goes from Rome to Sempronius Longus, the consul who is in Sicily with a large task force getting ready to invade Africa, that immediately gets called back. So that's one thing that Hannibal has gained. But's one thing that Hannibal has gained. But the other thing that Hannibal's arrival does is that it hugely impresses people who are naturally hostile to Rome, of which the most significant are the Gauls who live on the Italian side of the Alps. And Hannibal has to project the aura of a man who can genuinely
恐吓罗马人，他也确实做到了。他一到达意大利，罗马就向森普罗尼乌斯·隆古斯发出了绝望的召唤——这位执政官当时正率领一支庞大的特遣部队在西西里准备入侵非洲，他立刻被召回了。所以这是汉尼拔赢得的一点。但汉尼拔抵达带来的另一件事是，它极大地打动了那些天生敌视罗马的人，其中最重要的是那些住在阿尔卑斯山意大利一侧的高卢人。汉尼拔必须展现出一个能够真正
defeat the Romans Romans because otherwise the Gauls won't rally to his cause but if they do you know there are large numbers of them it's more than possible as we will see for Hannibal to get the size of his army back to what it had been when he left the Pyrenees. So this achievement of coming down from the Alps something that people would have thought impossible especially as he's done it with a load of elephants. Presumably, he knows perfectly well that as a PR coup, as a propaganda coup, nothing could be better fitted to impress the people he wants to recruit.
击败罗马人的领袖的气场，否则高卢人是不会团结到他的事业周围的。但如果他们加入了，你知道的，有大量的高卢人，正如我们将会看到的，汉尼拔完全有可能让他的军队规模恢复到他离开比利牛斯山脉时的水平。所以，从阿尔卑斯山下来这一成就——人们会认为这根本不可能，特别是他还带着一群大象——他大概很清楚，作为一场公关政变、一场宣传政变，没有什么比这更适合用来打动他想要招募的人了。
Yeah, so quote Eve MacDonald, who wrote a wonderful book about Hellenistic life. As news of his approach reached the Roman population, it must have seemed like the coming of a supernatural force. But I think you can say the same about the Gauls, and that's just as important. So he's followed the road of Hercules as Hercules had done. He's descended from the snowy peaks, you know, like a demi-god and he's done it with elephants. It is a stupefying achievement and one of the measures of that is that we are talking about it, you know, 2,200 years on.
是的，引用伊芙·麦克唐纳的话——她写过一本关于希腊化时期生活的精彩书籍——“当他逼近的消息传到罗马平民耳中时，这一定就像是一支超自然力量的降临。”但我想你对高卢人也可以这么说，这同样重要。所以他追随了海格力斯走过的路，正如海格力斯曾经做过的那样。他从白雪皑皑的山峰上走下来，就像一个半神半人，而且他还带着大象。这是一个令人瞠目结舌的成就，而衡量这一点的一个标志就是，我们在2200年后的今天依然在谈论它。
The elephants don't all die. Sometimes they all died, but they didn't all die. Most of them survived the journey. Is that right? We're not told how many survived, but it seems, I mean, essentially all of them seem pretty much seem to have survived. Okay. You know, again, their arrival creates such a sensation that the effort of bringing them, you know, is entirely justified, I think, just with the reverberation of the
大象并没有全部死去。有时人们说大象全死了，但它们并没有全死。它们大多数都在旅程中幸存下来了。是这样吗？我们不知道有多少只幸存下来，但看起来——基本上它们中似乎绝大多数都幸存了下来。好吧。你知道的，再次强调，它们的到来引发了巨大的轰动，以至于带它们前来的努力是完全值得的，我想，仅仅凭借关于他所作所为的消息所带来的反响。
news of what he's done. So now they are the emblem of everything that Hannibal is about, really. But having said that, obviously he has lost lots of men, and this potentially is a problem. But immediately, the moment he arrives, there's one tribe who are called the Insubres who do immediately flock to his banner, and Hannibal is very keen to demonstrate to other Gallic tribes that he's a friend worth having. So he immediately takes the side of the Insubres against a rival tribe, storms their stronghold, demonstrates the fact that he's got the muscle to do what he says he's going to do. And the result of this is that more Gallic tribes across what's now Northern Italy, the
所以现在，它们真正成为了汉尼拔所代表的一切的象征。话虽如此，很显然他失去了很多士兵，这潜在地是一个问题。但就在他抵达后不久，有一个被称为因苏布雷斯的部落立刻投奔了他的麾下，汉尼拔非常急于向其他高卢部落证明他是一个值得结交的朋友。因此他立刻站在因苏布雷斯一边，对抗一个敌对部落，攻克了他们的据点，展示了他有实力做到自己扬言要做的事。而这带来的结果是，贯穿现代意大利北部、波河平原的更多高卢部落发誓加入他的麾下。但这里有一个问题，那就是绝大多数这些部落都被西庇阿和他的军团与汉尼拔隔开了。执政官西庇阿从马赛归来，试图阻挡汉尼拔的去路，如今正挡在汉尼拔与他希望从高卢部落获得的增援之间。这对汉尼拔来说是个问题吗？其实这不是问题，这是一个机遇，因为他一直在寻找的、
Po Valley, they pledge to join his banner. But there is a problem, which is that the vast majority of these tribes are separated from Hannibal by Scipio and his legions. Scipio, the consul, who has come back from Marseille to try and block Hannibal's path and is now in the way between Hannibal and the reinforcements that he hopes to get from the Gallic tribes. Is this a problem for Hannibal? Actually it isn't a problem, it's an opportunity because what he is always looking for, what's
他的战略核心，就是与罗马人交战并希望彻底消灭他们。既然西庇阿的军团现在正挡在他的路上，那真是太棒了。放马过来吧。他想在冬季到来、使战事彻底无法继续之前，赢得一场对罗马人的决定性战役。没错，因为我们此时正处于深秋，大概吧。我的意思是，实际上已经差不多是冬天了。所以冬至就要到了。
key to his strategy is engaging the Romans in battle and hopefully destroying them. And the fact that he now has Scipio's legions in his path, you know, brilliant. Bring it on. He wants to win a decisive battle against the Romans before the winter season makes it absolutely impossible for campaigning to continue. Right, because we're in late autumn at this point, presumably. I mean, pretty much winter actually. So the winter solstice is approaching.
意大利北部的平原上开始刮起雪暴。因此距离局势变得不可能再战已经没剩多少时间了。所以这必须在汉尼拔抵达意大利之后的一两周内完成。好的。那么此时西庇阿在哪里？西庇阿是从哪个方向逼近的？所以他是从海岸线方向上来的。所以他是向东推进。没错。他现在正挡着汉尼拔的去路。而罗马人和汉尼拔部下在意大利本土上的第一次交锋，就发生在波河平原上。
The snow is starting to blow now in the plains of Northern Italy. So there isn't long before it will become impossible. So it's got to be done in a week or two really after Hannibal's arrived in Italy. Okay. So where is Scipio at this point? Scipio is approaching from which direction? So he's come up from the coast. So he's coming eastwards. Right. And he's now blocking Hannibal's path. And the first clash between the Romans and Hannibal's men to take place on Italian soil, it happens in the Po Valley.
当时平原上正刮着狂暴的雪暴，因此由于能见度显然很差，双方都派出了骑兵进行侦察。而罗马骑兵由西庇阿亲自率领，他身边带着他年轻的儿子普布利乌斯·科尔内利乌斯·西庇阿——这个人物将在汉尼拔后来的故事中扮演相当突出的角色。但现在，他只是一个跟随父亲服役的非常非常年轻的年轻人。他们出去了，结果迎头撞上了努米底亚骑兵，而罗马骑兵简直烂透了。努米底亚骑兵是世界上最厉害的，所以西庇阿和他的骑兵只好撤退。他们穿过了一条名为提契诺的河流。显然，他们输掉了这场
You've got snow storms gusting across the plains. And so both sides, because the visibility is obviously very poor, send out their cavalry to reconnoiter. And the Roman cavalry is led by Scipio himself, and he has with him his young son Publius Cornelius Scipio, who is a figure who will feature quite prominently in the later story of Hannibal. But for now, he's a very, very young man serving at the side of his father. and they go out and they run into the Numidian cavalry and the Roman cavalry is pretty rubbish. The Numidian cavalry is the best in the world and so Scipio and his cavalry retreat. They cross a river called the Tequinas. It's clear that they have lost this kind of
开局的小规模冲突，但这算不上灾难。罗马深知其力量历来在于步兵。区区几个骑兵阵亡算得了什么？所以他与主力部队汇合了。他们迂回穿行。西庇阿正试图寻找最佳地点，一个既能防御、又能为打击汉尼拔提供作战空间的地点。他在一条名叫特雷比亚的河流旁找到了这样的地方，
opening skirmish, but it's not a disaster. Rome knows that its strength always lies in infantry. Who cares if a few cavalrymen get killed? So he joins up with his main body of men. They zigzag around. Scipio is trying to find the best spot, somewhere that's defensive, but will provide scope for prosecuting the war against Hannibal. And he finds it by a river called the Trebia,
并在那里扎营。他现在正在做的是等待森普罗尼乌斯和他的部下从西西里赶来。以便将两支庞大的罗马军队合二为一。因为他想确保自己能够绝对稳妥地粉碎汉尼拔。好的，汉尼拔就在附近扎营，对吧？那么现在的问题我想是，
and he sets up camp there. And what he is doing now is waiting for Sempronius and his men to arrive from Sicily. So to unite the two big Roman forces. Because he wants to make absolutely certain that he can crush Hannibal. Okay, and Hannibal is camped nearby, isn't he? Now the question I guess is
此时正值12月，通常两军都会退守冬营。汉尼拔大概想要迫使局势爆发，以此来彰显实力，他想击溃罗马人，从而折服这些他急于拉拢到自己阵营的高卢人，他是这么想的吗？是的，甚至连汉尼拔获胜的提契诺小冲突的消息，也为他在当地高卢人中赢得了巨大的赞誉。既然罗马人已经从他们前进的道路上撤退了，许多人便纷纷前来加入汉尼拔的事业。在汉尼拔抵达意大利并在提契诺获胜后不久，他原本带着2万名步兵，现在随着高卢人的加入，步兵人数已经上升到大约28,000到30,000人。他的骑兵也增加到了大约1万名。
at this point we're in December and normally both armies would retreat to winter quarters. Hannibal wants to force the issue presumably to impress, he wants to smash the Romans to impress these Gauls that he's keen to bring over to his side, Is that what he's thinking? Yeah, and even the news of the skirmish at the Tacinus where Hannibal has won, wins him huge plaudits among the local Gauls. And now that the Romans have retreated from their path, lots of them can come and join Hannibal's cause. Within a very short time of Hannibal's arrival in Italy and his victory at the Tacinus, he came with 20,000 infantry, he's now up to about 28,000, 30,000 infantry with the Gauls coming in. He's up to about 10,000 cavalry.
所以再次体现出高卢人在壮大他的兵力，这对于罗马人来说显然是个巨大的问题，因为这意味着西庇阿现在想要尽快迫使一场战役爆发，以试图阻止高卢人胡作非为。但他需要等待森普罗尼乌斯的到来。而森普罗尼乌斯终于从西西里赶到了，不是吗？他让部下进行了一场强行军。现在罗马人的步兵远多于汉尼拔。我看着笔记上写着：38,000人对汉尼拔的28,000人，不过汉尼拔的骑兵更多，而罗马人
So again, this sense that the Gauls are swelling his numbers, and this is a huge problem obviously for the Romans because it means now that Scipio wants to force a battle as quickly as possible to try and stop the Gauls from misbehaving. But he needs to wait for Sempronius to arrive. And Sempronius finally pitches up from Sicily, doesn't he? He's sent his men on this kind of forced march. And now the Romans have far more infantry than Hannibal. So I'm looking at the notes, 38,000 to Hannibal's 28,000, although Hannibal has more cavalry, and the Romans are
在骑兵方面总是略有欠缺。但有趣的是，森普罗尼乌斯同样面临着发动战役的压力，因为他的执政官任期即将结束，他渴望用一场胜利来为自己的任期画上圆满的句号。所以你看，罗马的政治压力在这里发挥了作用，推动局势走向激化。是的。所以波利比乌斯说，西庇阿不想强行开战。西庇阿在提契诺负了伤，这让他失去了指挥资格。
always a little bit deficient in cavalry. But interestingly, Sempronius is also under pressure to force a battle because his consulship is coming to an end and he wants a victory to round off his time in office. So there you have the kind of political pressures of Rome, you know, acting to sort of force the issue. Yeah. So Polybius says that Scipio doesn't want to force a battle. Scipio's been wounded in the Tacinus and this has invalidated him out.
所以将由森普罗尼乌斯指挥对阵汉尼拔。波利比乌斯说，哦，西庇阿认为开战是个坏主意。我认为这是因为波利比乌斯最终成为了西庇阿家族门下的一员。所以他总是试图把他们描绘成最完美的形象。我认为很显然，两位执政官都出于同一个原因想要一场胜利——因为这将在他们年底卸任之前为他们带来无上的荣耀。但正如我们一直在说的，他们需要在整个高卢化的意大利北部倒向汉尼拔之前，迅速将汉尼拔彻底铲除。所以我认为波利比乌斯在那里写错了。我认为强行开战绝对是罗马人的作战计划。
So Sempronius is going to command against Hannibal now. And Polybius says, oh, Scipio thought it was a bad idea to have a battle. This I think is because Polybius ends up a member of the household of the Scipios. And so he's always looking to cast them in the best possible light. It's clear, I think, that both consuls want a victory for the same reason, that it will redound to their glory before they have to lay down their office at the end of the year. But also, as we've been saying, they need to stamp Hannibal out quickly before the whole of Gallic North Italy rises up to his banner. So I think Polybius is wrong there. I think it's absolutely the Roman battle plan that
而汉尼拔对此心知肚明。他知道罗马人基本上是迫不及待地想要一战，因为我们以前谈论过他是如何拥有令人难以置信的情报掌控能力的，而罗马人认为这简直就是作弊。以至于他们被汉尼拔似乎能看穿他们心思的能力吓得神魂颠倒，甚至宣称他一直化装成各种颜色的假发和不同的衣着潜行侦察。不过，这难道不是典型的战斗叙事吗？即敌方国王或统帅化装成游吟诗人或别的什么人。
they are going to force a battle. And Hannibal is fully aware of this. He knows that the Romans are essentially spoiling for a fight because we've talked before about how he has an incredible mastery of intelligence and how the Romans see this as somehow cheating. And so they end up so spooked by Hannibal's ability seemingly to read their minds that they claim that he's been going around undercover disguised with wigs of various colors and changes of clothing. Isn't that a classic battle narrative though, that the enemy king or commander disguised himself as a troubadour or something.
就像阿尔弗雷德大帝做过这事，某某人也做过这事。是的，但罗马人可不会干这种事。这根本不是罗马人的行事风格。不，我想他们不会。所以这非常具有布匿式的背叛色彩，诸如此类。但汉尼拔很聪明，他要利用他们的急躁情绪来对付他们。他知道他们迫切渴望速战速决，他将利用这一点。是的，还有一点，如果罗马人不出去迎战，会显得他们很没用。不，他们可不想显得像个懦夫，汉尼拔再次展现出他对
And like Alfred the Great did this and so and so did this. Yeah, but Romans wouldn't do that. That's not at all Roman behaviour. No, I guess they wouldn't. So it's very kind of Punic treachery, all that kind of thing. But Hannibal is clever and he's going to use their urgency against them. He knows that they're desperate to force the issue and he's going to use that. Yeah, and also the fact that it makes the Romans look bad if they're not going out and fighting. No they don't want to look like wusses and again Hannibal understands that that's a key part of
罗马人心理的深刻理解——他们总是渴望进攻，总是急于掌握主动权，于是他制定了一套正合他们心意的作战计划。所以，这是汉尼拔与罗马共和国军队之间的第一场大战的场景。那是冬至前不久的一个冬天清晨的黎明。罗马人扎营在特雷比亚河的洪泛平原上。天寒地冻。夹着雨夹雪的阵风呼啸而过，时间还太早，军团士兵们才刚刚开始苏醒。突然间，从营地瞭望塔上的哨兵那里，他们听到了呐喊声、军号的吹鸣声，显然是敌军发动了进攻。森普罗尼乌斯本人被紧急召集到胸墙上，他向外望去，看到下方
their psychology that they're always keen to attack, always keen to take the initiative and so he works out a battle plan that makes play with that. So the scene of the first great military clash between Hannibal and the forces of the Roman Republic. So it is dawn on a very wintery morning shortly before the winter solstice. The Romans are camped on the floodplain of this river, the Trebia. It's icy cold. There are gusts of sleet, and it's so early that the legionaries are only just starting to stir. And then suddenly from the sentries on the watchtower of the camp, they hear cries, the blaring of trumpets, and it's obvious that there is an enemy attack. And Sempronius himself is summoned quickly to the ramparts and he looks out and he sees below that
进攻是由那些令人胆寒的努米底亚人发动的——那些备受畏惧的努米底亚骑兵，他们正骑马冲向营地，投掷标枪，回马撤退，然后又折返回来，投掷更多标枪，如此反复。据波利比乌斯告诉我们，森普罗尼乌斯确信这一定是汉尼拔主力部队向他逼近的先头部队。所以，你知道的，他不想被杀个措手不及。于是他命令全体部下列队前进，去赶跑努米底亚人。而西庇阿，根据波利比乌斯的说法（准确与否我们不得而知），则说：“喂，冷静点，这可能，你知道的，这可能是个诡计。军团士兵们还没吃早饭呢，
the attack is being launched by these terrifying Numidians, the much feared Numidian cavalry, and they're riding up to the camp, hurling spears, wheeling back, withdrawing, then coming back, firing more spears and so on. Sempronius, we're told by Polybius, is convinced that this must be the advance guard of Hannibal's main army who were coming towards him. And so, you know, he doesn't want to be caught out. So he orders all his men to form ranks to advance and to chase off the Numidians. And Scipio, according to Polybius, how accurately or not we don't know, says, hey, steady on, this could, you know, this could be a trick. You know, the legionaries haven't had their breakfast, you know,
多米尼克，他们还要吃早饭呢。”我赞同西庇阿。西庇阿是个很有见地的人。然而，正当森普罗尼乌斯说：“不，我们没时间吃早饭了。我们需要出去粉碎迦太基人。”时，他下令骑兵出击，去驱赶努米底亚人——而努米底亚人见罗马骑兵逼近，随即开始撤退。此时正处于战斗队形中的罗马军团，
dominant, they're going to have a breakfast. I approve of Scipio. Scipio is a man of great sense. But while Sempronius is saying, no, we haven't got time for breakfast. We need to get out there and crush the Carthaginians. So he orders his cavalry out to drive off the Numidians who promptly start retreating before the advance of the Roman cavalry and the legions who are now in full battle formation,
肚子咕咕直叫，满怀留恋地想着培根和鸡蛋，踏着雨夹雪的黎明，穿过洪泛平原，朝着特雷比亚河行军。这事对你来说挺个人化的，对吧，汤姆？因为你在我们开始录音前告诉我，你今天早上在格雷格斯（Greggs）吃了一顿非常糟糕的早餐。是的。所以这就好像你的——难怪你以如此饱满的激情和活力来讲述这段历史。我的意思是，你完全沉浸其中了。是的。我已经开始同情罗马人了。
stomachs rumbling, wistfully thinking of bacon and eggs, start marching out into the sleety dawn across the floodplain towards the Trebia. And this is personal for you, isn't it Tom? Because you told me before we started recording that you'd had a very poor breakfast at Greg's this morning. Yeah. So this is like your, it's no wonder that you're narrating this for such film and vigor. I mean, this is total immersion for you. Yeah. I've already feel for the Romans.
于是罗马人出发了：骑兵在前，看似在追赶努米底亚人；步兵在后，在泥泞中踩出啪嗒啪嗒的声音，朝特雷比亚河方向前进。努米底亚人涉水穿过了特雷比亚河。罗马骑兵紧随其后，接着步兵（你知道的）现在也不得不照做。所以他们来到了对岸，不仅没有吃任何早饭，现在还全身湿透。天气冰冷，（你知道的）他们的束腰外衣开始冻结在腿上，但他们继续向前行军。他们意识到可能会有遭遇埋伏的风险。因此，当他们向迦太基人推进时，右翼的士兵
So at the Romans go cavalry first, seemingly chasing off the Numidians, infantry behind squelching through the mud down towards the river Trebia. The Numidians splash their way through the river Trebia. Roman cavalry follow infantry, you know, now have to do the same. So they come out on the far back, not only have they not had any breakfast, they're now sodden. It's icy, you know, their tunics are starting to freeze to their legs, but they carry on marching forwards. They are aware that there might be a risk of an ambush. And so those on the right flank as they're advancing towards the Carthaginians
时刻警惕着任何树丛，因为他们知道高卢人尤其喜欢做的一件事就是藏在树林里，然后突然杀出并从后方发动袭击。但是多米尼克，那里没有树。没有树。那我把波利比乌斯对当地地形的描述告诉你。地形平坦，没有任何特色。看不到树林，只有一条河道，两岸高耸悬垂，长满了密密麻麻的荆棘和乱木。但显然，任何人都不可能藏在那里，因为要做到这一点需要具备欺骗和背叛的超自然品质。我想我们可以排除那个长满茂密荆棘河岸的河道了吧？是的。绝对没有任何人藏在那里的可能。所以此时此刻，在他们前方，透过
are looking out for any clumps of trees because they know that there is nothing that ghouls in particular enjoy more than hiding in trees and then pouncing out and attacking in the rear. But Dominic, there are no trees. There are no trees. So I'll give you Polybius' account of what there is of the landscape. The terrain is flat and featureless. There are no woods to be seen. Only a water course with high overhanging banks that were densely overgrown with thorns and brambles. But obviously there's no possibility that anyone could be hiding there because that would just require supernatural qualities of deception and treachery to do something like that. I think we can discount that water course with the thickly brambled banks, can't we? Yes. No prospect at all of anyone hiding there. So ahead of them now, emerging through the
雨夹雪，太阳大概在这个时候正艰难地从灰云中挣露出来。罗马人看到了迦太基人的战线。正中间是传统的步兵，两翼是骑兵，骑兵前方是一道屏障——大象。大象构成了足够具有威慑力的景象。这让人心神不宁。哪怕你吃过早饭也一样。没错。迦太基人——罗马人开始意识到——看起来就像是吃过一顿美景早餐的人。
sleet, the sun is, I guess by this point, kind of struggling to emerge through the grey cloud. The Romans see the Carthaginian battle line. Infantry in the centre, as is traditional, cavalry on the wings and a screen in front of the cavalry, the elephants. And the elephants are a sufficiently intimidating sight. This is unsettling. Even if you had breakfast. Exactly. The Carthaginians, the Romans, start to realise, have the look of men who have had a nice breakfast.
噢不。而且显然他们还做好了防备——当你吃过一顿美景早餐时。噢不。而且显然他们还通过在身上抹油来抵御雨夹雪。这能起到保护作用吗？我觉得这太荒谬了。我一直对此很好奇。显然是可以的。如果你外面下着倾盆大雨，而你走出去把油涂在自己身上，人们会
Oh no. And apparently also they have protected themselves against when you have had a nice breakfast. Oh no. And apparently also they've protected themselves against the sleet by oiling themselves. Would that protect you? I think that's laughable. I always wondered about this. Apparently it is. If you're pouring with rain outside and you went out smeared yourself in oil, people would
嘲笑你的，我想。嗯，是的，因为我想我们有（你知道的）保暖内衣之类的东西、防水衣物，而他们可能没有。但如果你没有，也许你可以用油。不管怎样，我们听到的就是这样。他们看起来状态很好。他们容光焕发、暖和、吃饱了早饭。所以当战斗打响时，你可能会以为罗马人已经战败了。一点也没有。哦，因为他们毕竟是世界上最精锐的重步兵。而且当然，他们的兵力超过了迦太基步兵。所以他们向前推进，开始大显身手。
laugh at you I think. Well, yeah, because I suppose we have, you know, thermal underwear and things, waterproofs, which they probably didn't have. But if you didn't, maybe you could use oil. Anyway, this is what we're told. They look good. They're glowing. They're warm. They're well breakfasted. And so when the battle is joined, you might think the Romans are already defeated. Not a bit of it. Oh, because they're just the best heavy infantry in the world. And also, of course, they outnumber the Carthaginian infantry. So they press forwards and they start doing their stuff.
他们开始刺杀、开膛破肚，切开挡在他们面前的西班牙人、利比亚人和高卢人的内脏。于是内脏开始流出，与泥泞和半融的雪混杂在一起，变得越来越滑。我的意思是，这是一个可怕的景象，双方都进行着愈发绝望的战斗。与此同时在两翼，首先是大象，
They start stabbing and eviscerating and slicing open the guts of the Spaniards and the Libyans and the Gauls who were facing them. And so guts start to spill out and it mingles with the mud and the slush and it becomes ever more slippery. I mean, a hideous sight, both sides fighting increasingly desperately. But meanwhile on the wings, first the elephants and
然后是迦太基骑兵，击溃了罗马骑兵——罗马骑兵本来在数量上就处于劣势，而且发现根本无法与大象和努米底亚人对抗。接着他们迂回包抄，开始攻击罗马步兵的侧翼。所以这就产生了一种微妙的感觉：罗马人的阵型——嗯，现在他们的阵型有三个面都被迦太基军队包围了。就在这时，多米尼克，突然在罗马军队的后方传来了一声可怕的呐喊。声音正是从你还记得的那条长满荆棘的河道里传出来的。埋伏在那里的不仅有汉尼拔藏匿的步兵，还有马匹。所以士兵们和他们的马匹一直趴在那里，大约有2000名努米底亚人，其中一半
then the Carthaginian cavalry have rolled back the Roman cavalry who were always outnumbered but just find it impossible to fight against elephants and Numidians. And then they wheel in and start to attack the flanks of the Roman infantry. So there's a slight sense in which the Romans are, well, I mean, three sides of their formation is now kind of surrounded by Carthaginian forces. And then Dominic suddenly in the Romans rear, a terrible cry. And it is coming from the water course, you remember, with those brambles. And it's not just infantry that's been hidden there by Hannibal, it's horses as well. So the men have been lying there with their horses lying down, some 2000 Numidians, half
是骑兵，一半是步兵。他们一直在汉尼拔的弟弟马戈的指挥下驻守在那里。所以如果拍成范·迪塞尔主演的电影，我不知道谁会扮演他。他是一个时髦的年轻枪手，也许是汤姆·霍兰德。我不知道。你讨厌那样吧，对不对？不，我会喜欢。
of them cavalry, half infantry. And they've been stationed there under the command of Mago, who is Hannibal's younger brother. So in the film by Vin Diesel, I is Hannibal's younger brother. So in the film by Vin Diesel, I don't know who'd play him. He's a kind of hip young gun, maybe Tom Holland. I don't know. You'd hate that though, wouldn't you? No, I'd love it.
如果汤姆·霍兰德参演一部关于迦太基和罗马的电影，你绝对会讨厌死吧。不管怎样，马戈非常出色，是一位极其了不起的统帅。努米底亚人觉得他们完全智胜了罗马人，这简直滑稽透顶。他们猛烈冲撞罗马步兵的后方，此时罗马步兵基本已被包围。不出所料，罗马军队的阵线开始动摇、坍塌，随后崩溃。所有的纪律荡然无存，成千上万的士兵以各种可能的方式逃回特雷比亚河，试图在后方努米底亚人的阻击中艰难穿行。而在他们撤退时，这正是军队遭受真正惨重伤亡的时候。大象在践踏他们，骑兵在后面狂奔追赶、肆意砍杀，这场屠杀极其惨烈。但必须指出的是，这并非全军覆灭，因为
You'd absolutely hate that if Tom Holland was in a film about Carthage and Rome. Anyway, Mago is brilliant, tremendous commander. The Numidians think it's hilarious that they've totally outsmarted the Romans. They go crashing into the rear of the Roman infantry, who are now basically surrounded. Unsurprisingly, the Roman line wavers, buckles, and then it collapses. All discipline is gone, and you have thousands of men fleeing back to the Trebia any way that they can, trying to weave their way past the force of Numidians in their rear. And as they retreat, this is always when armies really suffer casualties. The elephants are trampling them down, the cavalry are galloping after them, hacking them down, and the slaughter is really terrible. But it has to be said not total, because the
如果汤姆·霍兰德出演一部关于迦太基和罗马的电影，你绝对会讨厌那样的。不管怎样，马戈很了不起，是一位出色的统帅。努米底亚人觉得他们完全智胜了罗马人，这简直滑稽极了。他们猛烈冲撞罗马步兵的后方，而罗马步兵现在基本被包围了。不出所料，罗马军队的防线开始动摇、坍塌，随之崩溃荡然无存。所有的纪律都荡然无存，数以千计的人以各种可能的方式逃回特雷比亚河，试图在身后的努米底亚军队中艰难穿行。正是在他们撤退的时候，军队往往会遭受真正的惨重伤亡。大象在践踏他们，骑兵在后面策马狂奔，疯狂砍杀，这场屠杀实在太惨烈了。但必须说明的是，这并非全军覆没，因为
center of the Roman battle line, about 10,000 men have actually broken through the Carthaginian ranks and they wheel around and they are able to get back to the Roman camp in relatively good order. But nevertheless, I mean, it is a crushing victory and it is a very, you know, literally chilling warning because it's icy cold to the Romans of the genius of the enemy that they are facing. And it's chilling, I think, because it's evident that Hannibal has completely thought himself into their sandals. He's worked out the way that they think. He's worked out their strategic muscle memory. He's demonstrated his mastery of surprise, and he has adopted this policy of surrounding a Roman army and then hopefully annihilating
罗马战线的中心，大约有10,000人真正突破了迦太基人的阵列，他们掉头转身，以相对良好的秩序回到了罗马大营。但尽管如此，我的意思是，这是一场粉碎性的胜利，而且这是一个非常，你知道的，字面意义上令人毛骨悚然的警告，因为罗马人面对的是敌人冰冷刺骨的天才。我认为这让人不寒而栗，因为很明显，汉尼拔完全把自己代入了他们的鞋子里。他摸清了他们的思维方式。他摸清了他们的战略肌肉记忆。他展现了他对奇袭的掌控，并且他采纳了包围罗马军队然后有望将其全歼的这一策略，
it that was almost successful. It's just the fact that these 10,000 men had managed to break out. And Sempronius and Scipio both got away, presumably. They both get away, yes. Yeah. You know, and they retreat back to Rome, kind of tails between their legs. And the news is greeted in Rome with real kind of terror because not only has he now crossed the Alps with elephants, but he's
几乎就要成功了。只是这10,000人设法突围了。而且塞姆普罗尼乌斯和西庇阿大概都逃掉了。他们都逃掉了，对吧。对啊。你知道的，他们夹着尾巴灰溜溜地撤回了罗马。罗马人听到这个消息时感到了真正的恐惧，因为他不仅带着大象穿过了阿尔卑斯山，而且他还
defeated two consuls in a pitched battle. So in Rome, there's immense trepidation and depression. But of course, across Northern Italy, since Alpine Gaul tribes are flocking to his banner and effectively Northern Italy is now under Hannibal's control. But the question is Dominic, what will the spring of 217 bring? That's the question on everybody's lips Tom and the answer will be forthcoming after the break. Hannibal continuing his advance on Rome passed through Etruria, burning and ravaging the countryside as he went, his aim being always to lure the Romans into attacking him. Sure enough, he soon saw that Flaminius was coming up fast in his rear.
在阵地战中击败了两名执政官。所以在罗马，人们感到了极大的不安和沮丧。但当然，在整个意大利北部，阿尔卑斯高卢部落正蜂拥聚集在他的旗帜下，实际上意大利北部现在已经处于汉尼拔的控制之下。但问题是，多米尼克，217年的春天会带来什么？汤姆，这是每个人都在谈论的问题，答案将在中场休息后揭晓。汉尼拔继续向罗马推进，穿过伊特鲁里亚，一路烧杀抢掠，他的目标始终是引诱罗马人攻击他。果不其然，他很快看到弗拉米尼乌斯正紧随其后追上来。
Hannibal continued along the road. To his left now were the hills that stretched beyond the city of Cortona, and to his right was Lake Trasimene. That that was Polybius describing the evening of the 20th of June, 217 BC. So we've moved on six months from the Battle of Trebia. And the scene is now moved from Northern Italy to Etruria, the land of the Etruscans, modern day Tuscany. So we're about 50 miles south of Florence. So Tom, what's the story?
汉尼拔沿着道路继续前进。现在他的左边是延伸到科尔托纳城外的群山，右边是特拉西梅诺湖。那是波利比乌斯对公元前217年6月20日傍晚的描述。所以我们从特雷比亚战役推进了六个月。场景现在从意大利北部转移到了伊特鲁里亚，伊特鲁里亚人的土地，也就是今天的托斯卡纳。所以我们在佛罗伦萨以南大约50英里处。那么汤姆，故事是怎样的？
What's Hannibal doing in Tuscany and who is Flaminius, his adversary at the Battle of Lake Trasimene? Okay. So Hannibal first, he's won this great victory at Trebia, but he then hasn't had a brilliant winter, chiefly because all his elephants, bar one, have died, which is very sad. Then just not used to the cold and the snow. Right. And the only one that survives is Cyrus, which is the, uh, the Indian elephant with the one tusk, um, which Hannibal from this point on, he's always kind of riding around on it. Right. And also what's disappointing for Hannibal is that although the ghouls have flocked to his
汉尼拔在托斯卡纳做什么？他在特拉西梅诺湖战役中的对手弗拉米尼乌斯又是谁？好的。那么首先是汉尼拔，他在特雷比亚赢得了这场伟大的胜利，但他随后的冬天过得并不精彩，主要是因为除了大象巴尔之外，他的所有大象都死了，这非常令人伤心。然后只是不习惯寒冷和雪。对。唯一幸存的是居鲁士，也就是那头单牙印度象，嗯，汉尼拔从这一点开始，总是骑着它到处走。对。而且对汉尼拔来说同样令人失望的是，尽管高卢人蜂拥聚集到他的
banner, there haven't really been any defections in the rest of Italy. And this is despite the fact that at Trebia, he had treated all his Italian prisoners with very ostentatious clemency, kind of sending them home, even as he keeps the Romans all kind of chained up as prisoners. So obviously, the Italians are not just going to rise up and cast off the Roman yoke. And he realizes, you know, which is always, I guess, he'd taken for granted that he's going to have to invade and come down southwards towards Rome, try and bring the Romans to another defeat. And despite the fact that he's now lost most of his elephants, he has reasons to feel pretty optimistic. So he's got all the Gauls, thousands and thousands
旗帜下，但在意大利其他地方并没有真正发生任何叛变。尽管事实是，在特雷比亚，他以非常高调的宽大态度对待所有意大利战俘，把他们送回家，甚至把罗马人全都当做囚犯锁起来。很显然，意大利人并不打算就这样起义并挣脱罗马的枷锁。他意识到，这也是他一直以来可能认为理所当然的，那就是他不得不入侵并向南推进朝罗马进发，试图让罗马人遭受另一次惨败。尽管他现在失去了大部分大象，但他有理由感到相当乐观。所以他拥有所有的高卢人，成千上万的人
now have flocked to his army, which is pretty much back to the size that it was when he left the Pyrenees, so back up to kind of 50,000 infantry and get 12,000 cavalry. And as ever, he's been keeping tabs on the Romans and he thinks that things that they're looking pretty good as well. So what of the Romans? Obviously there are still two consuls. The previous two consuls have stood down. There had been new elections, two new consuls elected. One of them is stationed at Ariminum, which is now Rimini, and he's there to block Hannibal should he try to advance down the eastern side of the Apennines, you know, which is this kind of ridge of mountains running down the spine of Italy. And the other is stationed at Aretium, which is modern day Aretzo in Tuscany to block and advance down the Western side.
现在已经涌入他的军队，这支军队的大小几乎恢复到了他离开比利牛斯山时的规模，即恢复到大约50,000名步兵和12,000名骑兵。而且和往常一样，他一直在密切关注罗马人的动向，他认为罗马人那里的情况看起来也相当不错。那么罗马人呢？显然仍然有两个执政官。前两名执政官已经卸任。进行了新的选举，选出了两位新执政官。其中一人驻扎在阿里米努姆，也就是现在的里米尼，他驻扎在那里是为了阻止汉尼拔试图沿着亚平宁山脉东侧推进，你知道的，这就是沿着意大利脊梁延伸的那条山脉。另一人驻扎在阿雷蒂乌姆，也就是托斯卡纳的现代阿雷佐，以阻止敌军沿西侧推进。
And the consul who is stationed at Aretium on the Western side is this guy, Flaminius. And Flaminius is not a nothing person, is he? Cause he's got experience of fighting the Gauls and he's a self-made man. He's not a pampered princeling. He's a man who's prospered by his own efforts. The Romans call him a novice homo. He's a guy who hit the first of his family to reach the consulship. Generally, the Romans are very keen on electing as consuls people from families who have a track record. So it's impressive that Flaminious has kind of made it to the top. And he's done this by, you know, as you said, by subduing a lot of the ghouls in Northern Italy. So the ghouls in Northern Italy have a real grudge against him. You know, they really, really hate him. Someone else who has a
驻扎在西侧阿雷蒂乌姆的执政官就是这家伙，弗拉米尼乌斯。弗拉米尼乌斯可不是无名之辈，对吧？因为他有与高卢人作战的经验，而且他是白手起家的人。他不是娇生惯养的纨绔子弟。他是一个靠自己的努力获得成功的人。罗马人称他为一个新贵。他是家族中第一个达到执政官职位的人。一般来说，罗马人非常热衷于选举那些出身于有良好纪录的家族的人担任执政官。所以弗拉米尼乌斯能够爬到顶峰，这令人印象深刻。他做到这一点是通过，正如你所说，征服了意大利北部的许多高卢人。所以意大利北部的高卢人对他怀有真正的怨恨。你知道的，他们真的，真的很恨他。还有一个人对他也
bit of a grudge against him is Polybius. Okay. Who doesn't think well of him at all says that he's a populist, a demagogue with no talent for the practical conduct of war and exceedingly self-confident. And there's a slight tone of the New York Times writing about a MAGA official in Trump's cabinet about it. About Pete Hegseth. That's how I'm imagining him. Yeah, that's the kind of vibe, I think. And so unsurprisingly, Hannibal thinks, well, this is the guy I'm going to target. I mean, you would. Hexeth is the man you target, right?
有些怨恨，那就是波利比乌斯。好吧。他对弗拉米尼乌斯的评价一点也不高，说他是一个民粹主义者，一个没有实际战争指挥才能的煽动者，而且极端自信。这听起来有点像《纽约时报》在写特朗普内阁中的MAGA官员的感觉。关于皮特·海格塞斯。我就是这么想象他的。对，我想就是那种氛围。所以毫不奇怪，汉尼拔认为，好吧，这就是我要针对的目标。我的意思是，你也会这么做。海格塞斯就是你的目标，对吧？
So what he does, he moves at lightning speed across the Apennines before Flaminious even realizes what's happening. He takes a kind of a path that again, no one is expecting him to take. It's quite tough and demanding, but you know, by this point, his men are used to going up mountains. He then advances through this very kind of marshy swampland around the river that no army had ever thought to cross. And it takes Hannibal's men four days to do it. And Hannibal himself, who rides through the swamps on Cyrus's elephant, he gets an eye infection and it can't be healed because they're in the middle of a swamp.
所以他所做的是，以闪电般的速度穿过亚平宁山脉，甚至在弗拉米尼乌斯意识到发生了什么之前。他走了一条再次让人意想不到的路线。这相当艰难和苛刻，但你知道的，到了这个时候，他的部下已经习惯了爬山。然后他穿过了这条非常泥泞的沼泽地，绕过了一条从没有军队想过要渡过的河流。汉尼拔的部下花了四天时间才完成。汉尼拔本人骑着居鲁士的大象穿过沼泽，结果感染了眼疾，由于身处沼泽中央而无法治愈。
And so he ends up losing it. That's a hell of an eye infection. it can't be healed because they're in the middle of a swamp. And so he ends up losing it. That's a hell of an eye infection. My God. Yeah, it was clearly pretty serious. And so from this point on, you know, he's like Nelson, he's only got one eye. Always a good sign in, I think, in a commander. Right. As with Nelson, so with Hannibal, it undoubtedly adds to his allure.
所以他最终失去了这只眼睛。那可真是严重的眼疾啊。无法治愈，因为他们身处沼泽中央。所以他最终失去了这只眼睛。那可真是严重的眼疾啊。我的天。是的，显然相当严重。所以从这一点开始，你知道的，他就像纳尔逊一样，只有一只眼。我认为这对于一个指挥官来说总是一个好兆头。对。正如纳尔逊一样，对于汉尼拔来说，这无疑增添了他的魅力。
And there were Romans who kind of draw up lists of the generals and enemies that they faced who had one eye. There's actually a surprisingly large number, but they all agree that Hannibal is the top one-eyed enemy that they've had. It's like an early episode of the Rest is History, history's greatest one-eyed people. So anyway, Flaminius, he has no idea what's going on. Hannibal is taking roads that no one had ever thought that he would. And so by the time that he
有些罗马人会把他们面对过的只有一只眼的将军和敌人的名单列出来。实际上数量多得惊人，但他们都一致认为汉尼拔是他们遇到过的最顶尖的独眼敌人。这就像是早期版本的《历史余音》（The Rest is History），历史上最伟大的独眼人物。所以无论如何，弗拉米尼乌斯，他完全不知道发生了什么。汉尼拔走的是没有人料想到的道路。因此，当他
clocks the Carthaginians have made it into Atruria, they have passed him and are heading south towards Rome. And again, to quote Polybius, the Carthaginians began to ravage the countryside. And as columns of smoke rose on all sides, bearing witness to the devastation. So the consul became ever more indignant and the wasting of the land is obviously it's positive because it means that Hannibal can strip it bare of all its riches and its corn and its livestock and things. But it's also deliberately trying to provoke Flaminius, who is the kind of guy who is very liable to be provoked. You know, he doesn't take kindly to this kind of stuff. So Flaminius doesn't hesitate. He sends word to his colleague saying, you know, cross over the Apennines and we'll catch the
突然发觉迦太基人已经进入伊特鲁里亚时，他们已经超越了他，正向南朝着罗马进发。再次引用波利比乌斯的话：“迦太基人开始蹂躏乡村。滚滚浓烟从四面升起，见证着这片土地的满目疮痍。”因此执政官变得越发愤怒，土地的荒芜显然是积极的，因为这意味着汉尼拔可以剥夺它所有的财富、谷物、牲畜和各种东西。但这也是为了故意激怒弗拉米尼乌斯，他正是那种很容易被激怒的人。你知道的，他可受不了这种事。所以弗拉米尼乌斯毫不犹豫。他派人向他的同僚传话，说：“你跨过亚平宁山脉，我们就能用钳形攻势抓住
Carthaginians in a pincer movement. And he then sets off in hot pursuit. He's not at this moment aiming to force battle. He's only got two legions. He's outnumbered pretty much two to one by the Carthaginians. But as I say, you know, the aim is that hopefully once the other console has crossed the Apennines, then they can squeeze Hannibal and kind of get him, surround him. So for this to work, Flaminius can't afford to lose track of the Carthaginians. So Flaminius and his men are tagging the Carthaginian army, and this is the scene with which you opened in the late afternoon of the 20th of June. And the situation is ahead of Flaminious and his men, the Carthaginians are continuing along this road, which is snaking past this great lake called Trasimene, very, very wide, very deep. And on the other side of the road is, as Polybius describes it,
迦太基人。”然后他便急起直追。他此刻的目的并不是强行开战。他只有两个军团。在人数上，他处于劣势，差不多是迦太基人的二分之一。但正如我所说，你知道的，目标是希望一旦另一位执政官跨过亚平宁山脉，他们就可以夹击汉尼拔，并设法包围他。为了让这个计划奏效，弗拉米尼乌斯不能失去对迦太基人的追踪。所以弗拉米尼乌斯和他的部下紧咬着迦太基军队不放，这就是你在6月20日傍晚开场时看到的场景。当时的情况是，在弗拉米尼乌斯及其部下的前方，迦太基人正沿着这条道路继续前进，这条路蜿蜒穿过这个名为特拉西梅诺的大湖，非常非常宽，非常非常深。而路的另一边，正如波利比乌斯所描述的那样，
an unbroken line of lofty hills. So lake on one side, unbroken line of lofty hills on the other, and the road is going between them. Now, Flaminious, I mean, he may be headstrong, but he's not an idiot. He realizes it would be very foolish to take a road like that. As the shadows are lengthening. And so he decides to pitch camp on the edge of the lake. And then in the morning morning he will see where the Carthaginians are before deciding whether to kind of follow the line of this very narrow
是一排连绵不断的巍峨群山。所以一边是湖泊，另一边是连绵不断的巍峨群山，道路就在它们之间穿行。现在，弗拉米尼乌斯，我的意思是，他可能有些固执己见，但他并不是个白痴。他意识到走这样一条路会非常愚蠢。随着夜幕阴影拉长。于是他决定在湖边扎营。然后在第二天早上，他将看清迦太基人的位置，然后再决定是否要沿着湖泊和群山之间这条非常狭窄的
road between the lake and the hills. Dawn breaks and there's a very heavy mist hanging over the lake and indeed the road and the foothills of the mountains. And Flaminius can't actually see what lies ahead in the road. So he sends his scouts clattering down the road and then they come back and say, yeah, brilliant news. We can see the Carthaginians ahead of us. They've taken the road and we can see their rear guard and they're just kind of going over the hills beyond late Trasimene. So we really need to get a move on because otherwise we're going to lose them. Yeah. And so Flaminious goes, right, quick, all action stations.
道路前行。黎明破晓，湖面上以及道路和山麓上都笼罩着一层浓重的迷雾。弗拉米尼乌斯实际上看不清路上前方有什么。于是他派侦察兵顺着道路飞奔而去，他们回来后说：“太棒了，好消息。我们能看到前面的迦太基人了。他们已经上了路，我们可以看到他们的后卫部队，他们正越过特拉西梅诺湖后方的群山。所以我们真的得快点行动，否则就要跟丢他们了。”是的。于是弗拉米尼乌斯说：“好，快，全员进入战备状态。”
Probably they do have time for breakfast this time, but you know, the trumpets are blaring, they're all kind of getting ready and they start snaking along this road between the lake, the hills kind of rising up on their, on their left, going along, going along and sure enough, the mist breaks briefly and Flaminious is able to see that Hannibal's rear guard is still in the process of climbing up the hills from the valley. And so he orders his men forwards and they engage and the Roman vanguard crashes into what Flaminius is assuming is Hannibal's rearguard and the battle begins. But just as it begins to the horror of Flaminius, to
可能这次他们真的有时间吃早饭，但你知道的，号角声震天响，他们都准备好了，开始沿着这条路鱼贯前行，左边是湖泊，群山在他们左侧拔地而起，走啊走，走啊走，果不其然，迷雾短暂地散开了，弗拉米尼乌斯得以看到汉尼拔的后卫部队仍在上山的途中，正从山谷爬向群山。于是他命令部队前进并交战，罗马先头部队猛烈撞击了弗拉米尼乌斯所认为的汉尼拔后卫部队，战斗开始了。但就在战斗刚开始时，令弗拉米尼乌斯惊骇的是，令
the horror of the Roman column that is now stretched all along the road between the mountains and the lake. They hear the sudden blaring of war trumpets from the mist-swayed heights above them. And then they hear the massed battle cries of some 30,000 men, Africans, Spaniards, and of course, particularly Gauls, and the Gauls, these are people who have real beef with Flaminius. And to quote Polybius
绵延在山脉和湖泊之间道路上的罗马纵队惊骇的是，他们听到上方云雾缭绕的高处突然响起了激昂的军号声。接着，他们听到了大约30,000名士兵震天的战喊声，有非洲人、西班牙人，当然还有特别多的高卢人，而高卢人，这些人与弗拉米尼乌斯有着不共戴天之仇。引用波利比乌斯的话
on how the Romans react to this unexpected development, "'The sudden appearance of the enemy took Flaminius completely by surprise. The mist blotted out all visibility, and with the attack being launched from higher ground and from so many points at once, the Centurions and military tribunes were not only unable to issue any of the necessary orders, but even to grasp what was happening, they found themselves under attack simultaneously from the front, the flanks and the rear. So the whole column is being attacked.
来描述罗马人对这一突发事件的反应：“敌人的突然出现让弗拉米尼乌斯完全措手不及。大雾遮蔽了所有的能见度，由于敌人是从高处以及如此多的方向同时发起进攻，百夫长和军事保民官不仅无法下达任何必要的命令，甚至无法理解到底发生了什么，他们发现自己同时遭到来自正面、侧翼和后方的攻击。”所以整个纵队都在遭到攻击。
So the whole thing was a trick, right? Hannibal had tricked them. Yeah. It's an ambush and Hannibal yet again has pulled off his favorite stunt, which is to kind of envelop and surround an enemy and then just press in and crush it to death and the Romans, you know, they are doomed. There is no way they can get out of a trap like this. So they fight hard.
所以这一切都是一个陷阱，对吧？汉尼拔欺骗了他们。是的。这是一场伏击，汉尼拔再次施展了他最拿手的把戏，那就是包围并合围敌人，然后向前压进并将其彻底碾碎，罗马人，你知道的，他们死定了。他们根本不可能逃出这样的陷阱。所以他们奋力抵抗。
I mean, they fight for three hours, pretty impressive. But Hannibal's men who essentially, you know, they had doubled back in the night to take up positions along the line of the hills and Hannibal had left some of his men to pretend to be the rearguard to tempt the Romans in. So very cunning. Right. But there's no way that the Romans can get out of this. Some of them do try wading out into the lake, but again, hopeless, you know, they either drown or they get hunted down by horsemen who come splashing after them. Flaminious himself is cornered by a band of the Gauls whom he had conquered and they decapitate him and wave the head in triumph. I mean, quite, quite battle, the little big horn.
我的意思是，他们坚持战斗了三个小时，相当令人印象深刻。但汉尼拔的部下基本上，你知道的，他们在夜里折返回来，在山脉沿线占据了位置，汉尼拔留下了一些人假装成后卫部队来诱惑罗马人上钩。非常狡猾。对。但罗马人根本无法逃脱。其中一些人确实试图涉水逃进湖里，但同样无济于事，你知道的，他们要么淹死，要么被随后冲入水中追杀他们的骑兵猎杀。弗拉米尼乌斯本人被他曾经征服过的一群高卢人逼入绝境，他们砍下了他的头颅，并挥舞着头颅欢呼胜利。我的天，这简直就是一场经典的惨败，就像小大角战役一样。
Yeah. And the vanguard, so the guys who had been sent ahead, they do manage to break free of the trap, but it's no good. They're subsequently cornered and taken prisoner and Flaminius's entire army, 25,000 men wiped out. What a twist. What a shock for the Romans. Complete shock because the news is brought to Rome and a magistrate climbs up onto the
是的。而先头部队，也就是那些被派到前面去的人，确实设法摆脱了陷阱，但这没有用。他们随后被逼入绝境并被俘虏，弗拉米尼乌斯的整支军队，2万5千人全军覆没。多么戏剧性的反转。对罗马人来说是多么巨大的打击。完全是毁灭性的打击，因为消息传到了罗马，一名地方官爬上
roster in the forum to announce to the people the result. So it's like announcing the football results or something. We have been defeated in a great battle. We have lost 13-0 and there is worse to come because three days later news arrives in Rome that a force of 4,000 cavalry who'd been sent ahead by the second consul who was imagining that he'd be joining up with Fluminius, he'd been sent ahead, they've been ambushed, wiped out as well. So terrible news. So a massive emergency for the Romans. They presumably now have to take desperate measures. They do. And fortunately for them, there are provisions within the constitution of the
广场上的讲台向民众宣布结果。所以这就像宣布足球比赛结果之类的。我们在一次大战中战败了。我们以0-13的比分输了，而且还有更糟的在后头，因为三天后消息传到罗马，第二位执政官派遣的一支4,000人的骑兵部队——他当时以为自己会与弗拉米尼乌斯会合——被派到前面去了，他们也遭到了伏击，全军覆没。真是个可怕的消息。对罗马人来说是一场巨大的紧急危机。他们现在大概不得不采取绝望的措施了。他们确实这样做了。幸运的是，在共和国的宪法中，对于这样的时刻早有规定。
republic for such a moment. And essentially what they decide to do is to suspend the rule of the city by the consul, so by the two elected magistrates and to appoint a single man to take their place. And this is, you know, this is a very momentous decision because everything about the Roman Republic screams out against any idea of obeying a single leader. It's a kind of legacy of their expulsion of the monarchy. But it isn't, you know, as I say, it's not unconstitutional. Provisions do exist for them to appoint this magistrate who is called in Latin dictator, which in English is essentially he who makes the decisions. And by tradition, the dictator serves with the legions on foot, unlike a normal, you know, a consul would be on a horse so he could see everything.
基本上他们决定做的是暂停由执政官（也就是两名当选的地方官）对城市的统治，并任命单个人来代替他们。你知道的，这是一个非常重大的决定，因为罗马共和国的一切都在强烈反对任何服从单一领袖的想法。这是他们驱逐君主制的某种遗留产物。但正如我所说，这并非违宪。宪法确实规定了他们可以任命这样一位地方官，在拉丁语中被称为“独裁官”（dictator），在英语中基本上就是指“做出决定的人”。按传统，独裁官随步兵军团一同作战，不像通常情况下，执政官会骑着马以便能看清一切。
The dictator is with the mass of the infantry. So he needs a second in command who serves as what is called the master of horse. And both the dictator and the master of horse, they only serve for six months. And the hope is that within the six month period, the crisis can be averted and then everything can go back to normal. And so the person who is appointed dictator is a guy we've already met before, Quintus Fabius Maximus Bericosus Warty, who was the guy who had very possibly gone to Carthage and held up his toga and said, I have peace and war in the folds of this toga and let slip war.
独裁官与大批步兵在一起。所以他需要一个副手，担任所谓的“骑兵长官”。无论是独裁官还是骑兵长官，他们都只任职六个月。人们希望在这六个月内危机能够解除，然后一切都可以恢复正常。因此被任命为独裁官的人是我们之前已经遇到过的一位老熟人——昆图斯·费边·马克西穆斯·韦科苏斯·沃蒂科索斯（Quintus Fabius Maximus Verrucosus），也就是那个很可能去过迦太基、展开他的托加长袍并说“我把和平与战争都折在这件长袍的褶皱里，你们选战争吧”的那个人。
Yeah. And he was the person who had been a little bit reluctant about rushing into war with the Carthaginians. I'm going too far to call him a dove, but he'd been more cautious than some of his colleagues. Yeah, so he's celebrated for kind of qualities of prudence and moderation, but you're right, he's certainly not a dove. He's actually a very formidable general. He again is a very seasoned gall fighter. He had brought a lot of the tribes and the foothills of the Alps under Rome's rule. He'd celebrated a triumph for it. So he's seen as ideally suited. He's not going to rush into an ambush. He's a proficient general, but more than that, he is emblematic
对。而且他也是那个对于仓促对迦太基开战表现得略微有些迟疑的人。说他是温和派可能有点过头了，但他比他的一些同僚更加谨慎。是的，所以他以审慎和温和的品质而闻名，但你说得对，他绝对不是什么温和派。他实际上是一位非常令人生畏的将军。他同样是一位经验丰富的高卢战争老兵。他将阿尔卑斯山麓的许多部落置于罗马的统治之下。他为此举行过凯旋式。所以他被视为理想的人选。他不会盲目冲进伏击圈。他是一位精干的将军，但更重要的是，他象征着
of everything that the Romans admire in a statesman. So he comes from a very distinguished family, unlike poor Flaminius. His own grandfather had served as a dictator in a previous crisis and come out of it very well. He himself is 58 years old and to the Romans, people in their late 50s, I'm delighted to say are seen as excellent people to entrust the future of the country to. So basically he's a man who can be trusted to steady the ship. So this is agreed. Fabius is inaugurated as dictator in a weird midnight ceremony that's so secret that no one really knows what's going on apart from those who actually officiate. And from that moment on, Fabius is in command of Rome and he spends his first day making sure that no ritual
罗马人对政治家的一切崇高赞誉。他出身于一个非常显赫的家族，这与可怜的弗拉米尼乌斯不同。他自己的祖父曾在先前的危机中担任过独裁官，并且表现得非常出色。他本人已经58岁了，对罗马人来说，我很高兴地说，五十多岁的人被认为是把国家未来托付给他们的绝佳人选。所以基本上他是一个可以被信任来稳定大局的人。于是各方达成一致。费边在一次神秘的午夜仪式中就任独裁官，这个仪式极为保密，除了实际主持仪式的少数人外，几乎没人知道发生了什么。从那一刻起，费边开始掌管罗马，他花的第一天时间确保没有任何关于神的仪式、
or ceremony or sacrifice to the gods has been neglected because the assumption is that the gods are angry. So they need to get the gods on side. Next, he orders the walls of Rome to be repaired and the bridges over the Tiber to be pulled down, so to make the city itself secure. He then sets about recruiting two new legions, so Flaminius' two legions have been wiped out, they need to be replaced, and he joins them with the two legions of the other consul, so now there's a field army of four legions, maybe 40,000 men, so about the number
典礼或献祭被忽视，因为人们假设诸神正在发怒。所以他们需要争取神的庇护。接下来，他下令修复罗马城墙，拆毁台伯河上的桥梁，以确保城市自身的安全。然后他着手招募两个新军团，因为弗拉米尼乌斯的两个军团已经全军覆没，必须得到补充，他将这些新兵与另一位执政官的两个军团合编，这样现在就有了四个军团的野战部队，大约40,000人，这与汉尼拔的兵力大致相当。
that Hannibal has, but he is not intending to engage Hannibal in battle because he realizes that his men are, they're not sufficiently trained, they're not sufficiently battle hardened. They need to buy time to give these legions time to kind of become sufficiently hardened to fight with the Carthaginians. So instead his policy is always to shadow Hannibal's men and I'll quote Plutarch, Plutarch the great Greek biographer who pairs famous Greeks with famous Romans and Fabius is one of the famous Romans he writes the biography of and in that biography he describes how Fabius shadows Hannibal. If the Carthaginians kept their position then he did as well. But
但他并不打算与汉尼拔正面交战，因为他意识到他的部下训练还不够充分，还没有经历足够的战火洗礼。他们需要争取时间，让这些军团有时间变得足够成熟，以便与迦太基人作战。因此，他的策略一直是尾随汉尼拔的部队。我引述一下普鲁塔克的话，普鲁塔克这位伟大的希腊传记作家，喜欢将著名的希腊人与著名的罗马人配对，费边就是他为其撰写传记的著名罗马人之一。在那本传记中，他描述了费边如何尾随汉尼拔。如果迦太基人坚守阵地，他也会这么做。但
the moment they moved he would descend from the heights and draw up his men just far enough away to avoid being drawn into a battle that he had no wish to fight, yet near enough to inspire in Hannibal a fear that he was going to fight at last. And these are obviously very unglamorous tactics, but they're effective. So they can start cutting down enemy foraging parties, picking them off. They can menace Italian cities that might be kind of wavering, might be thinking, oh yeah, we should sign up to Hannibal. And of course, all the time he's able to drill and train his raw recruits and to give them experience of being on campaign. So definitely, you know, there are a number of successes being chalked up. And he's playing a long game, right? He's
只要他们一移动，他就会从高处下来，把部队排开，距离刚好足以避免被卷入一场他根本不想打的仗，但又足够近，足以让汉尼拔产生一种他终于要开战的恐惧。这显然是非常不引人注目且毫无光彩的战术，但它们很有效。因此他们可以开始消灭敌人的粮草搜寻小队，零星地干掉他们。他们可以威慑那些可能在动摇、可能在想“哦对啊，我们应该投靠汉尼拔”的意大利城市。当然，与此同时，他能够操练和训练他的新兵，让他们获得行军作战的经验。所以毫无疑问，有许多成功正在不断积累。他在下一盘长棋，对吧？他
basically relying on Rome's institutional kind of economic and manpower advantages that in the very long run, as long as he waits and waits and doesn't get tempted into a decisive battle, he will win and Hannibal will lose. That's his thinking. So it's a difficult one because as you say, on the one hand, he's playing the long game, but on the other hand, he can't afford to let Rome's reputation be trashed.
基本上依靠的是罗马在制度、经济和人力方面的优势，只要他等待再等待，不被诱惑去进行一场决定性的战役，从长远来看，他就会赢，而汉尼拔会输。这就是他的想法。所以这是一个艰难的局面，正如你所说，一方面他在下长棋，但另一方面他承受不起让罗马的声誉被彻底毁坏的代价。
And this becomes a real issue when Hannibal invades Campania, which is the kind of the rich wealthy lands that surround Naples, Vesuvius, Pompeii, Capua, those kinds of places. And Hannibal just starts stripping it bare and torching the villas and the estates of various Roman luminaries. But Fabius is still not tempted. He insists still we're going to shadow Hannibal. We're not going to engage in battle. And people in his army, people back in Rome start to mutter and they start to give him hostile nicknames. So one of these nicknames is Cunctator, Delayer, and another one is Pedagogus, who is the slave who carries the books of
当汉尼拔入侵坎帕尼亚时，这就成了一个真正的问题。坎帕尼亚是那片环绕那不勒斯、维苏威火山、庞贝、卡普阿等地的富饶丰产的土地。而汉尼拔开始对其实行三光政策，烧毁了各种罗马名流的别墅和庄园。但费边依然没有被诱惑。他仍然坚持我们要尾随汉尼拔。我们不与敌交战。他军队里的人，罗马城里的人开始发牢骚，并开始给他起带有敌意的绰号。其中一个绰号是“拖延者”（Cunctator），另一个是“学童伴读”（Pedagogus），也就是罗马学童上学时替他们背书本的奴隶。费边当然注意到了这一点，尤其是因为他最大的批评者其实是他自己的副手，也就是他任命的骑兵长官。
a Roman schoolboy when he's going to school. And Fabius of course is aware of this and all the more so because his leading critic is actually his own deputy, the man he's appointed as master of horse. And this is a former consul called Marcus Minucius Rufus. And matters come to a head when Hannibal needs to leave the Campanian Plain and there's an obvious route for him to take which Fabius has blocked. So there's a pass and Fabius has put a garrison to block the pass and he's stationed his own men on the heights looking down at it. Hannibal is not the kind of guy who's going to be outsmarted by that kind of thing.
这位副手是一位名叫马库斯·米努基乌斯·鲁夫斯的前执政官。当汉尼拔需要离开坎帕尼亚平原时，矛盾终于爆发了。汉尼拔有一条显而易见的路线可走，而费边已经将这条路堵死。那里有一个山口，费边派了一支守军去封锁山口，并将自己的部下部署在俯瞰该处的高地上。汉尼拔可不是那种会被这种把戏难倒的人。
So he waits until nightfall and then he orders all his men, and this is a favorite trick, he's already done it, to light torches and to make it look like they've made camp. And then he gets burning torches and he ties them to the horns of a great herd of cattle. And then he whips the cattle up the side of a hill away from the pass. So the sentries on the pass looking out into the dark, they see these torches starting to move up
于是他等到夜幕降临，然后命令他所有的部下——这又是一个拿手的把戏，他以前就用过——点燃火炬，营造出他们已经扎营的假象。接着，他找来燃烧的火炬，把它们绑在了一大群牛的角上。然后他把牛群驱赶到远离山口的山坡上。因此，守卫在山口、注视着黑暗的岗哨看到这些火炬开始从
from the Carthaginian camp up the side of the mountain. And it looks as though this is the rope that the Carthaginians are taking, that they're trying to make a breakout in the dead of night. So the garrison on the pass go rushing off to where these torches are blazing, only to find that it's a great herd of cattle. And meanwhile, Hannibal and his men have gone up over the pass and have made their escape. I mean, if he's played that trick more than once, you have to say the Romans are total
迦太基人的营地向上移动，沿着山坡移动。这看起来就像是迦太基人正在走的路线，他们正试图在夜深人静时突围。于是山口的守卫急忙冲向那些火炬熊熊燃烧的地方，结果却发现只是一大群牛。与此同时，汉尼拔和他的部下已经翻过山口逃之夭夭了。我的意思是，如果他不止一次地玩过这个把戏，你不得不说罗马人真是十足的
mugs to fall for its second time. It doesn't look good. And Fabius, of course, is made to look an absolute idiot. And so whisperings against him start to turn to open criticism and back in Rome these criticisms are sufficient that Fabius' enemies are able to force a vote which obliges him to share his powers and his legions equally with Minucius. So essentially dictator and master of horse are now the equivalent of consuls, both are equally commanding two legions. And Hannibal, of course, is delighted by this, because what he wants is a kind of hot-headed Roman commander. And this is exactly
大笨蛋，居然第二次又上当了。这看起来可真不妙。而费边当然显得像个绝对的白痴。因此，针对他的私下耳语开始变成公开的批评，而在罗马城内，这些批评的声音足以让费边的敌人迫使通过一项投票，强迫他与米努基乌斯平分权力和军团。所以基本上，独裁官和骑兵长官现在相当于执政官，两人均等地各自指挥两个军团。而汉尼拔当然为此感到高兴，因为他想要的就是一个头脑发热的罗马指挥官。这正是
what he has with Minucius. And it's not long after Minucius has taken over his two legions that he lures Minucius into a trap. It looks like these two legions are going to be wiped out. Fabius comes storming down to the rescue. Menusias is rescued. And that evening, very shame face, Menusias leads his men to Fabius' headquarters and he salutes the commander that he had so traduced as father. Oh my word, very embarrassing for Menusias. Yeah, and very noble moment. Let me be the first, he declares to abrogate and annul the decree of the people that awarded me the joint command. And then the dictator takes him by the arms and embraces him and confirms him in
米努基乌斯目前的真实写照。在米努基乌斯接管他的两个军团后不久，汉尼拔就把米努基乌斯引诱进了一个陷阱。看起来这两个军团要全军覆没了。费边风驰电掣般赶来救援。米努基乌斯得救了。那天晚上，米努基乌斯满脸羞愧地带领他的部下走到费边的指挥部，向他曾经百般诋毁的指挥官尊称为父亲。哦天哪，对米努基乌斯来说太尴尬了。是的，这是一个非常高尚的时刻。“让我成为第一个，”他宣称，“废除和取消授予我联合指挥权的人民决议。”然后独裁官双臂抱住他并拥抱了他，确认他继续担任
his post as second of command as master of horse. So very, very noble. And the six months of Fabius's appointment as dictator pass, and there are no more engagements and people even back in Rome, except that for the now his strategy has probably been a good one. But when he lays down his dictatorship, I don't think there's any feeling in Rome and probably even Fabius doesn't think it that it would be sensible to carry on this policy, to perpetuate it.
副手即骑兵长官的职务。所以这非常非常高尚。费边担任独裁官的六个月任期过去了，再也没有发生其他交战，甚至连罗马城内的人也开始承认，他的战略可能一直是个好战略。但当他卸任独裁官时，我认为罗马没有任何人会觉得，甚至费边自己也不会觉得继续推行这项政策、将其永久化是明智的。
Essentially that Fabius' dictatorship was all about buying time, about recruiting, training more legions and then hopefully engage Hannibal in a great battle and wipe him out because that's what Romans do. They engage their enemies in battles and they annihilate them. And Dominic, as you keep reminding us, the key to Rome's greatness is its manpower. And I think the thinking in Rome is, well, this is the superpower we have to harness. We have to recruit and arm and train an army that is so vast, so formidable that there can be no prospect of Hannibal defeating it. So on the 1st of January, 216, Tom, two new consuls take up office and ahead
基本上，费边的独裁统治完全是为了争取时间，为了招募、训练更多的军团，然后希望与汉尼拔进行一场大战并将其彻底消灭，因为这才是罗马人的一贯作风。他们与敌人交战并将其歼灭。多米尼克，正如你一直提醒我们的那样，罗马伟大的关键在于其人力。我认为罗马人的想法是，这就是我们必须利用的超级力量。我们必须招募、武装和训练一支如此庞大、如此强大的军队，以至于汉尼拔绝无可能将其击败。所以在公元前216年1月1日，汤姆，两位新执政官就职，前方
lies the great showdown with Hannibal because everybody expects, don't they, that in the new year there will be a third pitch battle against the Carthaginians and this time surely the Romans will be victorious. And whether they are victorious, we will find out in the next episode. Now, in a startling innovation, we've started a club called the Rest is History Club. And if you join that club, you can hear that episode, the Battle of Cannae, one of the most dramatic battles, not just in ancient history, but in all history. You can hear that episode right now. If you remember the Rest is History Club. That's amazing value, Dominic.
迎来了与汉尼拔的终极决战，因为每个人都期待着，不是吗？在新的一年里，将会有第三场与迦太基人的阵地战，这一次罗马人肯定会取得胜利。至于他们是否能取得胜利，我们将在下一期节目中揭晓。现在，作为一项令人惊叹的创新，我们成立了一个名为“历史余音俱乐部”（The Rest is History Club）的俱乐部。如果你加入这个俱乐部，你就可以听到那一集节目——坎尼战役，不仅在古代史上，而且在整个人类历史上最戏剧性的战役之一。你可以马上收听那一集节目。只要你加入“历史余音俱乐部”。多米尼克，这真是太划算了。
Oh, the value is off the scale. It is such good value because you get ad free listening, you get a load of benefits that, I mean, so glittering. God, I might sign up for it. Yeah, I mean, I've signed up multiple times actually, because I love it so much. Anyway, you can join this club at therestishistory.com and whether you join it or not, we will be back next time with the most dramatic and thrilling and unexpected battle in all history. The Battle of Cannae. Bye bye.
哦，这性价比简直爆表。这太划算了，因为你可以享受无广告收听，还能获得一大堆福利，简直闪闪发光。天哪，我自己都想去注册了。是的，我的意思是，实际上我已经注册了好多次了，因为我太喜欢它了。无论如何，你可以在 therestishistory.com 加入这个俱乐部，无论你是否加入，我们下次都会带着历史上最戏剧性、最惊心动魄、最意想不到的战役回归。坎尼战役。再见。
Bye bye. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course any one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC Premier or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest of history. And
再见。大家好，你们还在。在节目快结束的时候，我对你们的执着印象深刻。但听着，我有个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一个问题。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众听到的不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西，而是关于我的品牌的广告。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一个方法可以知道那会是什么样。你可以打破广告的常规。你可以成为下一个汇丰尊贵理财（HSBC Premier）或许多其他在《历史余音》上做过广告的非凡公司之一。并且
you could put your brand in front of millions of like minded listeners by advertising on the rest of history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to GoalHanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以通过在《历史余音》以及Goalhanger网络旗下的其他节目上投放广告，将你的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是Goalhanger网络。Goalhanger正是制作这个节目的公司。如果你正考虑提升你的品牌价值，Goalhanger非常乐意倾听你的声音。你可以立即访问GoalHanger.com注册你的兴趣或你公司的兴趣。网址是 Goal，拼写是 G-O-A-L，Hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R 点 com。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。